Боїнг 737 української авіакомпанії SkyUp виконував рейс з Ташкенту до Києва
саме у ті хвилини, коли Росія почала своє вторгнення в Україну.
На підльоті до України, над Грузією, літак раптово переспрямували в Молдову.
Капітаном того рейсу був Сергій Булат.
Уже тоді - в небі - пілот розумів: вдома щось відбувається.
Ми летіли з Ташкенту на Бориспіль, коли отримали команду про посадку в аеропорту Кишинева.
І вже після посадки ми отримали доступ до інтернету
й дізналися про масштаби того, що сталося.
Авіакомпанія вирішила залишити екіпаж у Молдові.
Тож саме Сергій Булат першим почав виконувати евакуаційні рейси.
6 березня ми виконали перший евакуаційний рейс із Кишинева на Тель-Авів.
Далі звідти гуманітарний вантаж назад на Кишинів.
Після цього ми почали літати майже кожен день.
Як пригадує пілот, тоді для евакуації не вистачало екіпажу.
Пізніше до нього доєднався колега - капітан Геннадій Фоменко.
Разом вони зробили близько 25 рейсів.
Це залежало більше від того, наскільки інтенсивно під’їжджали біженці.
Там був табір для біженців, і як тільки на них були готові документи,
набирався повний літак - ми виконували рейси.
Було багато інвалідів на цих рейсах.
Десь по 30-40 інвалідів. Було таке, що по 40 тварин на борту.
Також всі вивозили собак, кішок і так далі.
Разом з колегами Сергій Булат врятував тисячі людей,
поки його найрідніші залишалися в Україні.
У мене родина в цей момент знаходилась в Борисполі.
Дружина - військовослужбовець, донька жила у військовій частині разом з нею.
Тобто було доволі важко.
Проте ані емоційне напруження, ані виснажливий графік,
згадує пілот, тоді не мали значення.
Адже кожен політ - це рейс врятованого життя.
Звісно, це доволі важко було, але що тут сказати…
Я розумів на той момент, що все, що я можу робити для нас всіх
- робити свою роботу просто.
Через напад Росії авіаційні працівники втратили роботу.
Владислава Фалько дуже довго йшла до того, щоб втілити свою мрію
- стати бортпровідницею.
Утім, за спеціальністю вона встигла попрацювати лише два місяці.
24-го почалася війна, а 25 у мене повинен був бути рейс.
Вже все було підготовлено, форма була випрасувана.
Все було. І тут нам пишуть, що небо закрите. Все.
До роботи в небі Владислава повернулася лише у травні.
Перші два рейси були евакуаційні - теж до Ізраїлю.
Це були і мами з дітками, і люди похилого віку, і тварини.
Знаєте, це були і собаки, і коти. І хом’яки в нас навіть були.
Відчуття було таке, що ми їх не веземо до Тель-Авіву.
Ми веземо їх до Києва. В "Бориспіль".
Тому що в нас таке було відчуття українського духу.
Всі ось ці гуманітарні та евакуаційні рейси були з рідною душею. Українські такі.
Пасажири співали пісні, атмосфера була неймовірна, пригадує Владислава.
"Україна - понад усе!"
Емоційно важко було, але ми трималися, тому що на першому плані в нас була робота.
Щоб все було добре, щоб все було за нашими стандартами, так, як нас навчали.
Звісно, ми підходили до кожного й питали: як у вас справи, як ви, порозмовляймо.
Та найбільше Владиславі запам'ятався грудневий рейс у Стокгольм.
Тоді на борту летіло сто медиків, сорок з них - тільки-но з лінії фронту.
Ось тоді емоції, знаєте, так нахлинули.
Хотілося плакати, але ми не подавали виду.
Ми показували всім серцем і душею, що все буде гаразд, що "дякуємо вам за те, що ви робите".
Коли я вітала медиків, наших військових, знаєте, я руки ось так за спину:
"Доброго дня, вітаємо". Але я відчувала, що в мене мурахи.
Тому що хлопці, коли заходили, вони хотіли обійнятися,
а ми ж не можемо так, бо буде черга.
І ми такі: "Ми до вас підійдемо, ми обіймемось".
Потім, коли ми вже прилетіли до Стокгольма, то ми, напевно, з кожним обійнялися.
Саме цей політ назавжди залишив слід у серці бортпровідниці.
Саме тіло показувало, що люди з лінії фронту.
Знаєте, навіть важко сказати…
Є такий процес старіння, так, але ти дивишся на людину
й навіть не можеш сказати, скільки людині років.
Зараз Владислава як волонтерка допомагає українським дітям
з вивченням польської мови, дає онлайн-уроки.
Проте найбільше чекає нових рейсів.
Дуже хочеться вже літати. В Україні.
Напевно, перший рейс я дуже хочу полетіти з Києва до Харкова.
Про польоти українським небом мріє й пілот Сергій Булат.
Особливо важко, коли ти пролітаєш поряд з Україною,
ти її бачиш, а завернути туди неможливо…